back well today's show is all about the
holidays Thanksgiving is quickly
approaching but if you want to get your
friends together the day before and
celebrate friendsgiving coffee beach
house is the place to be and here to
tell us about some of their holiday
offerings for both tomorrow and Thursday
we have general manager Jason bartucci
Jason thank you so much for being here
my pleasure happy to be here you know
Thanksgiving is always fun to celebrate
with family but it's also fun to get the
friends together and kick off the
holiday celebration so tell us what you
guys are doing at Coffee beach house so
um Wednesday night it's our weekly house
party but this is a friendsgiving uh
friendsgiving version of it so after
nine o'clock we do have uh half-price
pasta so all our prices all our pastas
are half off after nine and we also have
uh some half off some split select the
specialty drinks with live DJ one of our
resident DJs uh is DJ sky and her and
her friends are going to be coming and
having a great time look it's a house
party just like you would get together
at your friend's house come to our house
we do the cooking we do the drinking we
also clean up afterwards amazing sign me
up for that and it's kind of fun because
you can indulge in all the Thanksgiving
fixings on Thursdays but hey if you want
some some pasta before that absolutely
actual Thanksgiving is this what's on
the menu so this is part of what's on
the menu okay we uh in front of us it
all smells and looks so good so we
actually start everyone off it's an
Italian style Thanksgiving right so
charcuterie we have some prosciutto
Mortadella you have to have a little bit
of that if it's an Italian restaurant
right we do have a little bit of pasta
so we have some house-made gnocchi as
well oh my favorite
um and then we get into some of our our
Mainstays so we have uh uh turkey
roulade so it's some white meat we roll
that with some dark meat as well as
stuffing over a little bit of white
beans some brachiola so some meat
because no good Italian dinner isn't
good without anything not the meat
Italian style green beans a little bit
of polenta
we also have a Booyah base so we're
doing a Zuppa deepest because you have
to have fish as well right so you have
all of it you have to have all of it
this is an Italian Thanksgiving after
all so yes and kind of a fancy
Thanksgiving I'm liking the creative
takes on the classic dishes and if
people still want to make reservations
either for tomorrow or Thursday can they
still do that do you have some tables
100 quote me I'll find you a table if
there isn't one I promise we'll get you
in all right because there will be a
table available so be sure to go hang
out hey you could do Wednesday and
Thursday thank you so much for being
here happy early Thanksgiving happy
friendsgiving happy friendsgiving please
enjoy thanks for being here Rocky I will
send